getting a hit in the US and you know I
always feel like for whatever reason
like the US is like this higher standard
in the music world like I think artists
feel like when they get one here they
really made it does it feel like you're
finally kind of like making it like now
that like things have kind of like
turned up for you in the in the states I
feel like we have more work to do
actually yeah you know for sure yeah
it's not a sense of oh we making it
happen but I mean I did break barriers
and I did um you know I did so much in
like 6 months and I'm so proud of myself
you know so I'm not even going to hard
on myself or beating on myself but I
know for sure deep down like you know we
got more work to do still so it's been a
busy six months for you huh MH yeah tons
of shows yeah I've seen you get like get
brought out do do special appearances
and stuff what has been your favorite
live moment so far performing [__] when
Derk rman out when little Dirk brought
you out yeah that had to be crazy what
city was that in um New Jersey in Jersey
yeah shout out to Dirk was for
Powerhouse shout out to Powerhouse too
oh yeah that was a Powerhouse yeah
Powerhouse was a movie man yeah that had
to be a movement man hey for you to like
having burnner boy get on the remix
that's that takes [__] to a whole
another level so like I can only imagine
like you know he's kind of like the the
Jay-Z of the afro beat wave that's
happening right now which is a little
different than what you're doing but
it's still kind of got to be a big big
uh deal for you to have him jump on a
record yeah what was that like when you
first heard the vocals when you first
got the email in you first put ears to
the remix it was not even an email I was
present you were there so he recorded in
front of you oh so you was there yeah
what was the session like it was dark it
was dark yeah but it it was it was fun
though it was exciting too you know I
was really excited like when he started
to go and I said yeah what's his writing
process like is it off the top of the
head there no right look let me tell you
something b a boy boded that REM right
100% And I will be honest with you the
way how he came up with that verse in
that like short space of time to M man
this man is talented gifted like out the
world crazy insane like insanely
talented are talking about like that was
like off the like it was off the top of
the head yeah like it was wasn't even
written like he didn't even stady up for
like a hour and like he went straight in
he just went in the booth and just I'm
telling you and the way how we even like
constructed the words to even be like S
is to Trinidad you know like it's
something like that is being like
thought about in the presence of course
because Prince Swan was present too from
Trinidad seeing kids and you don't know
he big up Jamaica as well too you know
100% yeah so it was it was it was a
moment like woo 100% % yeah all right um
no so for you man um talk talk about
your uh I know you got to be putting in
some work on an album right now yeah
what is the album sounding like and how
how how far along are you with with with
finishing it well um let's get in there
let's get in there you were just
listening to something right now when I
walked in so who when you walked when I
walked in you was listening to something
on your phone oh yeah that's something I
did last night with PR oh fire okay
shout out to PR from my OVO right yeah
that's my boy good guy man yeah um I was
going to say though like uh how far
along you think 50% 60% um 70 70% done
mhm do we got features
yet that means
yes maybe maybe yeah um who's your dream
feature like if you had to like you know
work with anybody if you could get a 16
from somebody right now who would it be
right now
yeah
um Rod wave Rod wave would be crazy love
Rod wave he's making some of the best
music out right now he's kind of like
feel like he's like he's like the
harmony God right now you know what I'm
saying like he does that melodic [__] on
like a another level shout out to Rod
wave